IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
"BARCROFT TV."
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
IF YOU DON'T KNOW,
BARCROFT TV IS A YOUTUBE CHANNEL
WITH TENS OF MILLIONS OF VIEWS
THAT SPECIALIZES IN REALLY
BIZARRE HUMAN INTEREST STORIES
TOLD TO YOU BY AN INCREDIBLY
EARNEST BRITISH NARRATOR.
OR NAR-A-TOR, AS THEY DON'T SAY
BASICALLY, THEY MAKE EXPOSEÉS OF
GIANT TUMORS AND SELF-TANNER
ADDICTS SOUND LIKE A PBS
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT THE MAGNA
CARTA.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A STILL
FROM ONE OF THEIR VIDEOS AND
I'M GONNA READ YOU TWO OPTIONS.
YOU TELL ME WHAT THE VIDEO IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT. OKAY.
FIRST ONE, THIS IS KYLE JONES.
DOES HE: DATE A 91-YEAR-OLD OR
MAKE HIS OWN EROTIC ACTION
FIGURES?
KAMAU?
>> I REALLY HOPE IT'S DATE'S
91-YEAR-OLD.
>> CHRIS: OH MY GOD.
>> I JUST WANNA THINK ABOUT IT.
AHHHHH.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, LET'S FIND
OUT.
>> BABY-FACED KYLE JONES,
LADIES' MAN --
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: NOW, KAMAU, WHAT'S HE
THINKING?
>> BREAK THAT HIP, BROTHER.
BREAK THAT HIP.
>> CHRIS: DO YOU DATE HER OR
CARBONDATE HER? I'M NOT
100 PERCENT SURE.
>> OH!
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
DOES THIS FUN COUPLE DRINK EACH
OTHER'S BLOOD OR PERFORM A
SATANIC CLOWN SHOW FOR THE
CHILDREN OF GOTHS.
GREG PROOPS.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY THEY PERFORM
A SATANIC CLOWN SHOW FOR THE
CHILDREN OF GOTHS.
>> I'D PAY TO SEE THAT.
>> EXACTLY.
>> CHRIS: THAT'S GOT TO BE WHAT
IT IS.
LET'S FIND OUT.
>> YOU WOULD BE FORGIVEN FOR
THINKING-- BUT THE GLASSES
ACTUALLY CONTAIN BLOOD.
>> MOST BLOOD HAS COPPERY IRON
TASTE TO IT.
>> YOU WILL NEVER, EVER FIND
FOOTAGE OF BLACK PEOPLE ANYWHERE
DRINKING EACH OTHER'S BLOOD.
YOU WILL NEVER FIND IT.
YOU CAN GOOGLE FOREVER.
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
DAMN YOU, WHITE PEOPLE!
DAMN YOU!
>> LAST ONE, DOES THIS WOMAN
SPECIALIZE IN MASSAGE FOR
REPTILES OR EXTREME YOGA FOR
BABIES?
TOM?
>> EXTREME YOGA FOR BABYIES.
>> CHRIS: LET'S SEE EXTREME YOGA
FOR BABIES.
>> NO!
NO!
>> CHRIS: GREG, YOU LOOK
PERPLEXED.
>> WELL I WOULD HAVE RATHER SEEN
THE BLOOD FOOTAGE AGAIN.
>> CHRIS: I THINK THIS GUY'S
INNER MONOLOGUE IS, "WHATEVER,
IF YOU DROP IT WE CAN JUST MAKE
ANOTHER ONE."
( LAUGHTER )